على مر التاريخ خلفت الفتوحات العلميه
والتقنيه فرصا جديده للبشريه لكن التقدم
السريع للذكاء الاصطناعي يثير ايضا العديد
من الهواجس والمخاوف من خروجه عن نطاق
السيطره يبقى ما فوائد الذكاء الاصطناعي
واضراره المحتمله على البشريه وما الدور
الذي ستلعبه هذه التكنولوجيا الجديده في
المستقبل وتاثيراتها على الاجيال المقبله
[موسيقى]
عباره عن سيناريوين السيناريو الاول ان
التكنولوجيا ستكون عصر يفقد فيه الناس
وظائفهم يتم سيطر على المواطنين من قبل
الحكومات الى اخرها من الافكار المظلمه
اما السيناريو ان عصر الذكاء الاصطناعي
سيكون عصر فيه يتم تطور الصناعه والطيب
ويتم في اعطاء مساحه اكبر للبشر للقيام
باعمال الابداعيه بدلا من الاعمال الخضراء
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي فوائده كثيره يعني اذا
نتكلم عن موضوع الطب اليوم الذكاء
الاصطناعي في المجال الابحاث الطبيه سابقا
اكتشاف عقار دواء جديد يتطلب مليار ونصف
دولار وياخذ 15 سنه باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي تحولنا من مليار ونص دولار الى
عده ملايين وعده اشهر حسب تقرير صحيفه
فورد موضوع الفضاء اليوم شركه سبيس اكس
تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي كو اوتو بايلد
للمركبات والصواريخ اللي تطلق للفضاء
موضوع الزراعه انه كيف الذكاء الاصطناعي
يساعد في رفع سله الغذاء العالمي انه
موضوع الكوارث الطبيعيه اليوم الذكاء
الاصطناعي يستخدم من اجل تحليل الطقس
ومعرفه متى واين سيحدث البرق ويسبب بكوارث
طبيعيه مثل الحرائق هذه التطبيقات يمكن ان
تكون قويه بالفعل يمكن ان تكون وسعه
الانتشار وقدراتها مميزه ولذلك
هذا يمكن ان يكون مكانا يمكن ان ننظر فيه
لكي ننهض باستخدام هذه الادوات بخلاف
الاعلام وبخلاف المجله الاخرى التي يمكن
ان تفرط الامور من عقالها فيها هل اليوم
هذه الفوائد مضمونه وهل يمكن استعماله
بطريقه سلبيه يمكن لان هذا الشيء يحتاج
الى ضمانات من قبل الحكومات ومن قبل
الشركات التي تمتلك
[موسيقى]
الذكاء الاصطناعي يوفر ثلاث امور للدول
اول هو الوقت قارن الذكاء الاصطناعي او
السي بي والواحد اللي يستخدم كمعالج في
الحاسبه في شخص كبشر السي بي يو 100 الف
ضعف سرعه تفكير البشر ثاني اللي يخدم بيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي هو موضوع الجغرافيا نفس
المساحه الجغرافيه تزرعها لكن تستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي ممكن تضاعف هذا الموضوع
المساحه الجغرافيه تكلم عن موضوع الموارد
البشريه اليوم مثلا دوله عندها مليون
كثافه سكانيه تبعها مثلا مليون او خمس
ملايين اذا تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
والروبوتات راح تضاعف من الموارد البشريه
لهذه الدوله اهم ميزه يوفرها لنا الذكاء
الاصطناعي انه قادر على التعلم بسرعه
وتقديم خدمات ذات خبره وذات جوده بزمن
قياسي جدا
[موسيقى]
كيف يمكن ان نقنن اللجوء الى الذكاء
الاصطناعي بحيث لا يكون مسرفا بدرجه ربما
قد قد تضر محاولته تصنيف المخاطر المختلفه
هنالك ثلاث طبقات هو في حدها العالي هو
كالتالي حيث تنتهكوا حقوق الانسان
الاساسيه واستخدام الشرطه او المراقبه
القارات المرتبطه بالحريه والهجره كان من
يقرروا اين هو مكمن المخاطر ولسوء الحظ
الشركات لديها قوه كبيره في الفتره
الراهنه لتقرير ذلك هنالك ايضا سيناريوهات
اخرى كالانتاج الزراعي التربه الصحه ايضا
المناخ ولا تنتهك حقوق الانسان ولا تنطوي
على
معلومات حساسه هذه المجالات يمكن للمشرعين
ان لا يتخذ
يدا صارمه ربما في التعامل معها
[موسيقى]
هؤلاء الخبراء دعوا الى العمل من اجل
التصدي لما سموه مخاطر انقراض البشريه
التي تشكلها تكنولوجيا الذكاء الاصطناعي
هناك مخاطر اثنين الاول اللي هو التهديد
الوجودي تهديد وجودنا او سيناريو الصراع
المحتمل بين البشر والاله وهذا الموضوع
انا استبعده كل التخوف حول الموضوع اساءه
استخدام هذه التقنيه الواجب علينا ان
نتعلم كيف نتعامل مع هذه الالات وهذه
الادوات الزرق الذين يستخدمون اياديهم في
عملهم فسوف يتاثرون ايضا نظرنا الى عالم
السيارات فان الادوات التشخيصيه التي
يستخدمونها سوف تتغير ربما بسبب
تكنولوجيات الذكاء الاصطناعي دعنا نقسم
الضرر التي سينتج عن الذكاء الاصطناعي الى
ضرر من نوعين هنالك ضرر نتيجه فوضى او او
ارتباك في الاسواق ارتباك في المجتمعات
ارتباك في الدول نتيجه بطاله كثيره نتيجه
سوء استعمال لذكاء الاصطناعي قد يتم
استخدام هذا الشيء في التاثير السياسي
تجاه المرشحين او الناخبين قد يتم هذا
الشيء في تضليل وكالات الانباء الخطر
الوجودي نحن نعرف الذكاء الاصطناعي
الموجود حاليا انه الشيء يتم تعليمه
تدريبه ليقدم نتيجه بسرعه وبجوده عاليه
لكن ان يمتلك الذكاء الاصطناعي وعي هذا
شيء خطير جدا انا اعتقد ان هذه المخاطر
يعني لا مفر من وجودها او وجودها كتهديد
لكن هل هي ممكن ان تكون يعني واقعيه وتؤدي
الى خطر وضرر حقيقي هذا يعني ينطلق من
قضيه كيف سيتم ادخال الذكاء الاصطناعي الى
الحياه العمليه وما هي القيود التي سيسمح
بها هل فعلا هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان
يخرج عن سيطره الانسان هذا واحد من سنوات
الحقيقيه اللي ممكن نواجهها لكن كما ذكرت
سابقا انه احنا بعيدين تسع سنوات عن هذا
الموضوع تنحافظ على سلامه النماذج اول شيء
انه احنا ما نطلق نموذج لاستخدام البشر
قبل التاكد من سلامته بالاضافه الى التاكد
من وجود الكولينج سويتش يعني احنا قادرين
على اطفائه رقم اثنين عدم تعليم نموذج
الذكاء الاصطناعي على البرمجه لاننا لو
علمنا الذكاء الاصطناعي على البرمجه ممكن
ان يعيد برمجه نفسه واذا عاد برمجه نفسه
ممكن ان يعني تكون مواجهه بيننا وبين
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الخطر هو عدم ربط
يعني تطبيق يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي على
تطبيق ثاني يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي لان
هنانا البشر يفقدون القدره على السيطره
على الذكاء الاصطناعيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي شكل راس الحربه في هذا
المقام وهنالك
قانون الذكاء الاصطناعي في الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكنه لا يضبط التطبيقات
العسكريه للاسف ولسؤلاء الحظ المشرعون
ما يزالون متلكؤون بخلاف الشركات شركات
الذكاء الاصطناعي
قد يكون هنالك قرارات لمنع ادخال الذكاء
الاصطناعي في بعض القطاعات الاعمال حفاظا
على الوظائف سيكون هنالك ايضا رقابه على
استخدام ادوات الذكاء الاصطناعي في
القطاعات التي تؤثر على البشر مثل خصوصا
القطاعات الطبيه قطاعات النقل لكن اتوقع
ان الحكومات ستدفع من اجل الشركات الكبيره
من اجل وضع خصائص جديده في نماذج الذكاء
الاصطناعي منها مثلا الفاكتشيك التاكد من
الحقائق قبل طرحها